لم يكن يعلم ذلك الفلاح الواقف في حقله
منذ عقود طويله انه سيرمي يوما ما بحساء
من اجل الحفاظ على البيئه حادثه كغيرها
تكررت في الاسابيع الماضيه وضعت متاحف
العالم في صدمه كبيره
الناشطون المسؤولون عن هذه الهجمات يسيئون
بشده الى تقديرها شاشات هذه الاعمال التي
لا يمكن تعويضها
عن صدمتهم العميقه ايذاء المخاطر غير
المدروسه على الاعمال الفنيه مؤكدين ان
المتاحف هي اماكن لاقامه حوار بين اشخاص
من افاق متنوعه عدا عن انها مواقع تساهم
في التبادلات المجتمعيه ولافتين ايضا الى
انه باتت على المتاحف اليوم مسؤوليه اكبر
عن اي وقت مضى
بالاستعراض والغرابه والعبث الخاطر احيانا
يسعى نشطاء البيئه في مناطق مختلفه من
العالم الى جذب انتباه وسائل الاعلام من
اجل الاهتمام بقضيتهم التي يصفونها
بالمصيريه بما يتعلق باستمرار الحياه على
سطح الكره الارضيه
وعلى الرغم من ان هناك اجماعا بشريا على
قضايا المناخ وسعيا عالميا لايجاد حلول
لها فثمت اجماع ثقافي ايضا على رفض تلك
سلوكيات خاصه ان الكثير منها يخالف
القانون فلم يتوانى 83% من المشاركين في
استطلاع اجرته هيئه الاذاعه العامه في
المانيا عن التعبير عن السياحه من مسلسل
تلك الاعمال المثيره معتبرين ان النصفاء
المناخ قد ذهبوا بعيدا جدا في تصرفاتهم
ملوك الشيخ العربيه